[Music]
the Republican conventions being held
this week in Tampa Florida we sent our
own correspondent to Tampa to cover the
Republican convention one of our writers
Deon Cole is there yeah well actually
dion landed in tampa this morning and
this is a true story unfortunately our
camera crew did not make it okay their
flight was canceled too due to the storm
so Deion's they're all alone no camera
crew I was told that just a couple of
hours ago but thanks to
videoconferencing dion is live with us
from tampa so please welcome mr. Dion
call let's talk to the 2012 Republican
National Convention with the unn cold
[Applause]
hey hey this is exciting you really are
in Tampa right now tell us what is it
like there in Tampa I am here calling it
and let me tell you it is a lot of old
people here I mean like you wouldn't
believe that handicapped parking space
is it blocks away from the hotel and
that was a real good parking space
okay all right well tell us is anything
I know that the storm delayed your
camera crew they won't be there till
tomorrow we hope but the Convention is
anything happening at the convention
well I went to the convention and let me
tell you it is bone-chilling white there
understand me I mean it is nothing but
khakis and loafers as far as I can see
and everybody keeps congratulating me on
my gold medal
[Laughter]
he gonna break that kind of thing can
happen sometimes Dion alright well you
are there all alone is it rough being
there all alone yes but look I know the
camera crew is stuck in Atlanta but I'm
your boy and I ain't gonna let you down
so what I did was I went to Best Buy and
I bought a camera see and here's the
receipt right here and I went and I did
my own report check it out get this
right
hey Connie what's happening I'm had the
2020 national gonna bet
[Applause]
that's it now the listeners the lesson
that I learned is that when you buy a
video camera it is not already charged
you have to charge it for eight hours
yeah supposed to know that I I didn't
know but I promise you we will reimburse
you for the camera okay oh no no you
only gotta rehearse me see I have the
show company credit card so what I did
was I treated myself and you know bought
me a couple things you know you don't
mind just get a receipt Deion that's all
I asked you yeah I'm call thank you very
much